hello good evening
you've got an incredible body of work
already and in the last few years
especially you've completely flipped the
script when it comes to what it means to
be a leading woman in Hollywood and
people finally seeing like all the
incredible talent that you possess what
advice do you have specifically for the
Asian diaspora who have unfulfilled
dreams from different versions of
themselves from different timelines and
universities
well hey good evening I hope you all are
having a good time it must be tough out
here
I hope you have drinks under your chair
but um that's a great question uh look
at me I mean I've been in the business
for 40 years and finally
I get to be number one on the call sheet
I think it simply goes to say it's like
if you believe in yourself you believe
and you have passion in what you do you
don't give up
right so and I do believe that times are
changing there there is much more
inclusivity there's more diversity and
it's not lip service anymore whatever
that glass ceiling was we just ninja
kicked it out of it you know we have to
we shattered it and we have to keep it
in that that way and but we have enough
and many
uh extraordinary filmmakers not just uh
on in movies but also TV that
are Forward Thinking to understand the
importance of inclusivity the importance
of diversity the importance of telling
stories about different cultures
different looks and embracing them all
in the right way simply because our
audience demands it so we are on this
cusp of
big change I think the change has
already started occurring I'm just so
happy that I'm still here when this has
the change has happened you know that
I'm not in my rocking chair and go like
why didn't I get that chance then so
I
am overwhelmed at this moment but at
least I am here
so I'm going to work hard that this is
not just going to be the only time I'm
here and for all that looks like us we
are going to move forwards and find
bigger and better opportunities thank
you
thank you
uh congratulations for media
um and so my question for you is like he
said like look look at you look at where
you are yeah
um how do you hope that your role in
everything everywhere all at once
inspires other Asian American women
since the movie is so significant for
our community
Evelyn Wong she was such a gift when the
script came to me
to you know when you're 60 and you're
sitting in the sidelines and you're
thinking hey you really had a good run
it's okay right you're not up there
but you don't you don't just sit back
and so when I did get an to look at the
script and go like wow the most
important thing for me was you're
talking about an immigrant Asian
actually it doesn't matter whether she
was Asian or not but it was important
for me she was Asian
aging woman who's frazzled by the world
who's trying to make an honest living
but still the world beats her down and
then suddenly she goes on all these
different multiverses but what she
discovered was in every Multiverse she
was still fighting for love fighting for
her family and that I think that's why
we all relate so deeply it resonates so
deeply with the audiences around the
world that that's what we all do we are
ordinary superheroes and we have
superpowers inherently in US kindness
love that's the superpower we don't need
that freaking Cape to tell us we are a
superhero and that's what we want to do
and I think in in this amazing movie
thanks to the Daniels who had the
audacity the courage to write it and put
it out there and send it to me like I'm
sure some executive would look at it or
like are you insane who would want to
know about hot dog finger us right who I
want to know about an Asian aging woman
right so but we did it we found people
who believe in us and that's what we
will keep doing we have to believe in
each other because it's such a healing
process and we've gone through really
tough times the last few years turmoil
covet freaking covet and again covet
that you know we need somewhere we can
go where we are doing this out of
kindness compassion love for each other
with each other along the way so that's
what we will keep doing
thank you
[Music]